here's to the next step to the next step
to the next step to the next step
this is the reunion that's been 20 years
in the making
what does it feel like to be back
together again yeah it's not everyone it
was kind of the same thing but like
everyone's life has changed so much a
lot of kids now yeah yeah except for us
yeah honestly whenever I see this group
it just really just takes me back and it
feels like no time has passed
when was the last time this many of you
were together in a room the last movie
yeah 2012 yeah yeah kids now are
rediscovering American Pie and they're
like oh my god this crazy movie we love
it what's it like and did you have any
idea that you were making this movie
that would still stand up 20 years later
definitely wild that people that were
born after we made it are now enjoying
it yeah I did not think that would
happen yeah I just remember like being
really excited for my friends to see it
cuz I knew that they'd really liked it
and then apparently a lot of other
people felt the same way because it was
huge it turned out okay yeah sense onset
I mean personally I felt like we were
part of something special I remember
when I read the script I thought I think
I could speak for all of us at that time
we were auditioning for all these team
movies there was kind of a new wave of
teen movies that were happening team
comedies especially and this definitely
stood out on paper and then when we got
the whole cast together we started
filming it and then especially in that
year between filming and its release you
know the red band trailer was released
and then that got all this but and and
it was really interesting because this
was you know internet was kind of
happening but not obviously in the way
it was all day yeah do you remember what
how life changed after the movie came
out big got tickets to some MTV Awards
ceremony and we were so excited and we
went there and we sat in the corner and
didn't speak to anybody but each other
and we did that and we saw Hanigan
having a great time yep
you came over you said hi to us yeah Ron
yeah absolutely
ready you are already a big Buffy start
yeah yeah yeah actually the three ladies
on the couch were already known oh yeah
and then fleshly meals the group yeah
and then we went to an MTV thing like a
year later and we actually had people to
talk to
yep and now we don't even get invited is
the cycle of life yeah was it though
crazy when you're walking around all of
a sudden people started yelling out
things from the movies you're
everybody's American Pie what they
scream well you can guess what they sold
right Oh in this one time at band camp
which was fine before I had children oh
but now I'd really like them to just be
like oh I recognize you wink wink I mean
I just yes luckily they don't finish the
sentence but I I stand there terrified
that they will do your kids kind of know
or do they have they have no I yeah
Allison I told your kids I figured what
does everyone else get for four years
everybody act like Stifler and yelled
[Music]
like they would wait till I walked by
and then give a huge you know like per
year probably a decade of that Wow that
doesn't work
variety they just call me Stifler's mom
actually call upstairs mom like I'm
confused what do you get I get out
a lot of it which was really bizarre
like little girls are kind of coming up
to me and asking me my advice if they
should like lose their virginity I'm oh
my god I don't know yeah yeah today
though there yet the Saturday after the
movie came out I was walking with my
buddy to go get breakfast and we were
like gonna cross the street and the car
came by and the kids in the car shouted
oh my god do the dance do the dance that
was like the first sort of moment that I
kind of had a sense that this thing was
bigger than I had ever envisioned was
that very next day so of course I did
the dance it was on Wilshire Boulevard
and I figured you did the dance yeah all
right but but I don't I don't get bad as
much nowadays I mostly just get oh it's
Adam Sandler yeah I get a lot of that so
that's fun and also my life what was it
like on set what was like the
camaraderie it's like this was it that's
actually true like this all the dynamics
that are happening now that I feel like
was very real like I remember Terra and
I were just talking about it we were all
just tremendous thing about her
apartment and you know I remember us
going there we used to order a lot of
Pizza is I feel like it was the only
food we were so young that we only
understood that you could order pizza
also time was different then you can
have cell phone you had to call up on
the landline and it was really only one
delivery service not not like today it
was actually in 1921 and and then we
usually put on you know hats and take
Polaroid dress up like me and apparently
in crazy outfit and take pictures and we
all had fun daily and please remember
something I was thinking about Sean I
don't know if you want to get into this
but I remember as a me phone call that
you called me once and what let's say me
phone call I'm thrilled about this come
on I'm kind of I can't remember
you kind of know where I'm going today
No yeah I thought to say I'm still very
flattered by this phone call Oh Sean do
you remember what happened hey I mean
I'm yeah are we uncovering sex secrets
here huh was there a little was there a
little something going on but it was
like we used to I mean we were young
people and I think we were all like you
know yeah I mean you had to dial it was
probably rotary you had to talk to the
operator listen all I remember is that
how sweet is it that we were young
enough that we were all like really why
did you turn it was here's a question do
you all how many of you went to high
school and just did all four years high
school yeah everybody yeah I didn't okay
you did okay
yeah how different was your experience
in this movie from real life yeah
drastically well I was always that was
the big curiosity for me about this in
many ways I think of this is the
weirdest movie I've done because it's
the one I understand the least I would
say just speaking honestly I was sort of
somebody that had not had a traditional
high school experience and that never
really fit in you know so I think I
always felt like I would say I love
these guys I mean we're you know
characters in the arts so I think I felt
you know loved and accepted and seen but
I think I always felt like it was such a
curiosity I'd never really done a sort
of you know prom or anything like that
so I didn't quite understand what what
it was that we were the story we were
telling it was very it was very
all-american very white it was very like
a very specific kind of story that I
didn't fully identify with and I was so
so
prized and delighted that it was so
relatable to the world at large like
what a gift to be able to kind of bring
joy to people but it was a relatability
that I I never really identified with
well I remember Chris was the first
person I had ever met that said he
really enjoyed high school it was like
what that is it's true the
counter-argument to Natasha's experience
is my experience which was in Omaha
Nebraska and very very the middle
America of it all with the jocks and the
choirs and oddballs and the acts and all
that sort of thing it was I when I read
it I got it I thought it was like oh
yeah this is exactly how we all grew up
and and and you know it was originally
called East Grand Rapids which is where
Adam hurts the writer is from Grand
Rapids Michigan which is a lot which is
an area a lot like where I was a kid and
you to Minnesota very similar do you
remember the controversy how people were
like oh my god this movie is outrageous
the teen sex and the things that are
happening and the penis in the pie when
my agent sent me the script they said
okay you're either gonna love it or hate
it people are very divided and some
agents think they shouldn't even send it
to their client yes so I I loved it
obviously I actually don't remember much
of a controversy saying and if it wasn't
funny it would have been a horrible
thing to show people but the fact that
people were laughing so much let us get
away with yeah way more than what you
know and all the stuff in the movie is
done with such sincerity like the
performances and the way that chris and
paul weitz directed us it's just so all
the performances are even as zany as
some of the lines are that's all
grounded in like this really groovy team
you know who are we kind of thing and a
lot of innocence and heart is
the right word all right Jason talked
about the pot there's pies everywhere
that scene I mean that was a
life-changing scene for you yeah sure
was what does it mean to you today let's
really take a moment and talk about this
it's funny when I read the script mm-hmm
I knew already that I was gonna be
reading for that that role and so I was
reading the whole script and then it got
to that scene and I laughed out loud and
and this was before Eugene was even cast
so I didn't really even fully know the
the degree to which it was going to be
hilarious but I just thought oh my god
that's amazing I've never read anything
like that never seen anything like that
and I remember saying to myself like
that I really hope I get this part I
really want to do that like that that
seems like something I would love to
sort of go for and I'm like I'm gonna be
a fearless commit and then the and I got
the part and then the day of filming
this scene I had a complete freak out
and I called my manager in my trailer
and I was like am I really gonna I'm
really gonna do this okay and I did I
just I needed that I had one moment of
freak out like what if no one sees this
what if absolutely no one sees this and
I just happen and then I'm the icecap I
for no other reason than just I got paid
very little money to PI and I kind of
freaked out but then he gave me a vote
of confidence and then I I went in there
and and I and I did it I did it and I
did it hard and I did good and it get
along beautifully I feel for Jason but
no I it's wonderful to be in a film that
like somebody remembers 20 years I came
out I just worry about my children and I
just don't want to have to answer this
question yet will they ever see the
movie god I hope I'm not around for
like ireally of course they are but like
just hopefully they're in college and
they just don't tell me can we talk
about Stifler's mom and problem and
really a phrase that you I mean you
basically made a phrase famous for the
next generation forever John Cho made
that phrase famous I never said it I
just did it I can't take credit for the
phrase what was it like working with
Jennifer amazing yeah does that buy you
crazy street cred for a while having sex
with Jennifer Coolidge I'm on screen I
don't know about street cred but women
you think he's trying to pick up yeah
we're to play a little game with you
guys this is called spill the pie was
there anyone who had a moment together
got a hookup no I had a crush on Chris a
bit of a crush on Eddie Elsa no I I
actually I had a crush on Alice the
opportunity for me yeah that was a
[Music]
really yeah if I could go back I would
try to hook up with Eddie and Sean and I
feel like that's one of my regrets and
I'm me and Jason have always been trying
to impress Chris Klein true story that's
like all I think we spent the whole
movie doing the second degree that's all
we did all 20 minutes we were just
trying to impress CK that's their way of
making fun of me right now not at all
not even a little bit as that is that
true was their press point anyone who
didn't get along that eventually became
friends 20 years ago I think we had any
beef what I really love about this crew
and like what we get to do today is we
could you know you asked us at the
beginning of this like when's the last
time you were all in a room together
it's a long time ago well with this
group it doesn't matter how long it is
we walk in the door and you would have
thought we would have seen each other
yesterday if there is one thing that
this movie means to you what comes to
mind for me if I may I feel like
such a it's me growing up I mean it's
it's to have to have this movie and be
able to have made the sequels and to
continue to have these relationships 20
years later I have literally grown up
from the time this first movie happened
and it's and what a wonderful group of
people to grow up with and what a
wonderful movie to be a part of and have
it you know sort of represent my life
sure it's just a dream come true I think
just to just to get an opportunity to be
in a movie and then have this amazing
experience it just changed my life it's
such a massive thing to be grateful for
to have you know any movie at all and
then to have it be something that
connects so deeply with people where
they feel like their experiences see you
still feel like loved and supported by
this crew is pretty it's a very its deep
stuff it's a stuff of like real life it
is something you you couldn't ask for
more than this you know I love the
script you never know what's gonna
happen like is it gonna turn out the way
you hope every step of the way it just
got better I see something the American
Pie it puts a smile in my face if
there's a real loyalty and I'm real and
it really it was a life-changing
experience we are all insanely blessed
and lucky that we just happen to be the
right age at the right time and go to
the audition and get the offers that's
it there's absolute gratitude I mean you
think about a movie that was that came
out 20 years ago that we now get to sit
and talk to you on a Entertainment
Tonight special 20 years later that's
that says it all right there it's uh
it's a pretty great thing and and and
all of us sitting here are real grateful
to Eddie's point right place right time
right age right you know
personalities
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]